[Music]
all right and are you ready
totally we are going to go through a
rosewood rundown right now
and I want the quickest answers you can
think of for these next questions first
person you ever thought was 8000 yeah
okay uh your craziest most jaw-dropping
moment of the whole series of the whole
series yeah in your opinion
oh I I thought it was hilarious when I
was not ad but I told her on a ski lift
I was like this is insane it's crazy and
then Lucy Hills crying face yeah so much
fun a couple that you shipped on the
show but it can't be your own I came to
my own hmm I know I always a big spender
Toby Toby spot slow be public a disease
but yeah fans
I've dealt spooby wolf you got three
years yeah
what is one word to describe the finale
one word to describe the finale
um whoo all engrossing lovely
heartbreaking that was like 97 words uh
and lastly what was your reaction when
you did find out who ad was I knew it
did you really it like Donna at one
point I was like I bet this thing person
place thing to be vague but I was like
oh yeah I get it this makes sense
have you seen fans guess it online yes
okay the truth is out there
totally perfect it's out there thank you
so much